If we believe more in modern medicine,
am I committing kufur because I'm not
having full faith in the words of the
prophet. The question posed by the
brother is that our beloved prophet has
many hadith is talking about the
medicines is known
as and the prophet has various hadith
talking about what will cure you, what
will not cure you, talking about honey,
talking blood seed and various. So the
question posed by a Muslim who is a
medical student that is it if I practice
something else if I don't practice the
medicine of the prophet and if I
practice like maybe alopathy or the
mainstream medicine so is it kuf is it
wrong if I don't believe in the world of
the prophet regarding the last part of
the question is it wrong if I do not
believe in the word of the prophet yes
it is wrong you have to believe in the
word of prophet But that doesn't mean
you have to practice that medicine also.
Practicing the medicine is not fur
because whatever the prophet told about
the medicine if you follow it's a
sunnah. The prophet never said it is far
that you should take honey. The prophet
spoke about the benefits of honey the
benefit of black seed that in this there
is cure for every disease except death.
But that doesn't mean it's a it is
sunnah. It's the makada prophet spoke
about the that if you use the and the
prophet said if it wasn't too difficult
I would have made it f for every Muslim
to use the shak before every salah but
he'll do it so using shivak is sunnah so
whatever the prophet recommended whether
it is whether it is cupping whether it's
honey whether it's black seed all these
are sunnah it's not a f it's not to do
it so but you cannot say what the
prophet said is wrong that is wrong. We
cannot say don't believe in the hadith
that is kufur. If it's a say hadith
prophet said this and if you deny it
then that is you cannot deny that but
it's not a must that you should follow
it if you're practicing it. Now you said
you're a doctor and there is an alopathy
medicine which may not follow the same
what the prophet has said. It's not
wrong at all because Allah says in the
Quran in chapter number 16:43 and
chapter number 21 verse number 7
firstly in Tal if you don't know ask the
person knowledgeable. So if you get sick
who will you ask you'll ask a doctor. So
now you're following the guidance of the
doctors in today's world. It will be a
non-Muslim problem. And the prophet was
very clear. There is a hadith in which
when people were hitting the plants and
the prophet said what are you doing they
hit the plants again the other the
plants and there to be pollination the
prophet and that year the crop failed
and then they realized that when they
used to do this action it was mainly
helping in pollination and the crop was
good so the prophet said these are
worldly
matters in worldly matters it's not
necessary you have to follow everything
what I In matters of dean in religion
yes you have to follow blindly but
matter of worldly things you may or may
not follow him it's not compulsory so as
far as medicine is concerned the native
medicine science has advanced so there's
no problem at all in you following what
the modern science say but that doesn't
mean you have to disagree with the say
hadith in which the prophet has given
treatment you can also use that you can
do both together so if you practice
general medicine or practice Alapati
medicine which is not the same as there
is no home at all. We're not doing a
film but see you don't criticize the
hadith in which the prophet has spoken
regarding the cure for many of the
diseases. Hope that answers the
question.